un réveillon original dans le gerse
maintenant avec boisson à travailler sur
place une vendange de nuit depuis 10 ans
les dernières grappe de pacherin c'est
un sépage sont ramassés le soir de la
saintsylvestre àel reportage Muriel la
saga David
Bress allez à la santé du pacherin ce
vin que l'on vendange la nuit du
réveillon av VII c'est comme ça depuis
plus de 10
ans le raisin presque confi et récolté
les derniers jours de l'année jusqu'au
dernières heures un peu pour le folklore
beaucoup pour la qualité du vin le Perin
de la sain
syvestre bien sûr qu'on se sert de
folklore mais c'est surtout on le fait
pour avoir un produit noble et excellent
vous gag qualité ah oui bien sûr oui
sinon on s'amusera pas le faire pour que
tout le monde s'amuse la partie de
vendange nocturne est ouverte à tous
d'ici et d'ailleurs pourquoi vous êtes
venu là parce que c'est le soir du
réveillon que j'avais pas envie de
m'enfermer dans une fumer je trouve que
c'est bien ça fait V un peu le village
je c'est pour lui rendre hommage que
viela célèbre en grande pompe la
résurrection du pacherin ce doux breuage
qui a bien failli disparaître et dont on
est pourtant si Friant mais vous croyez
pas qu'on est ici dans le coin pour
boire de l'eau non c'est pas parce qu'il
y a des sources à la montagne mais ça
elles arrive pas
jusqu'ici une pastorale créée par des
villageois bénévoles pris place dans
l'église le temps d'une histoire celle
de leur vigne celle des souffrances et
des
joies avant de goûter le vin nouveau le
spectacle s'est poursuivi dans le
vignoble je préserve la vigne d'autres
hier soir furent les hbles serviteurs du
pacherin bien décidés à
festoyer